I did want to talk about something
important here at the
very top of the show.
As some of you have
heard, it's been out there
for a while now, but
we're making it official.
We are winding down our TBS show.
The plan is to re-emerge on HBO Max
sometime in the near future.
with I think what will be my
fourth iteration of a program.
Imagine a cooking show with puppets
and you'll have the wrong idea.
Anyway, we're going to
be making this switch.
Now, some of you are probably wondering,
why am I doing this?
Why end things here at TBS?
And I'll tell you because
a very old Buddhist monk
once told me that to pick something up
you must first put something down.
Yeah.
Now I'll be honest with you,
he was drunk out of his
skull and very belligerent
and I maintained, you
can pick up two things
if you use both hands.
He just got mad and
started swinging at me.
So I ended the conversation
and took his advice.
We'll be moving on.
Our last episode here at
TBS will be on June 24th.
Now the plan is we're going to be showing
a lot of clips of our favorite moments
from the last 11 years.
We're going to have some special guests.
We're going to create, I think,
a really fun, special environment.
And it's going to be,
I think, a lot of fun.
And you know, I just want to
point out that for 11 years
the people at Turner have
been absolutely lovely
to me and everyone here at the staff.
They gave me a home when I needed one most
and I am eternally grateful.
I'm very proud of what
we've accomplished here.
And so what I'd like is I'd like
these last couple of weeks
to be a fond look back
at all the absurd madness that
my team and I have concocted.
Best of all,
I just want to point out
there will be shockingly few
if any, references to Donald Trump
because that's always been
my favorite kind of comedy.
So tune in these next
two months and check out,
as we say farewell to this show
and move on to the next horizon.
No one ever says the next horizon.
It's just what came to me in the moment.
Yeah, there's only one horizon.
There's only one horizon.
[Andy] Yeah, yeah.
I'm regretting the next horizon thing.
There's just one horizon.
It's all right.
Yeah.
I apologize.
Right.
As we head to that next mountain top, huh?
That's fine.
Okay.
[Andy] Yeah.
Over the horizon.
Although at this point
it'll probably just be
like a slight hill.
Just a small hill.
[Andy] We're old.
Yeah.
[Andy] Yeah.
I don't want to go up a mountain anymore.
I'm too old for that.
It'll be a slight rise.
Right.
And I'll be on one of those electric,
electric scooters you
see people in the mall
driving around in, yeah.
Cresting.
Anyway, so watch for that.
And we'll be talking a lot
about it in the weeks to come.
I just wanted to give
you a little heads up.